okay listen I got something wrong with
me that's the first thing to know I
twitch and shout a lot makes me look
like a damn freak show first cut that
out
touch it Bailey I'm sorry but inside my
heads an even bigger mess I can't stop
twisting things around words and sounds
especially have to keep playing with
them until they come out right sorry
she's figured I asked like I said a damn
mess then I started working for Frank
Frank men a private eye boys Frank
frankly frankly Frank Oh
he's the one who taught me how to use my
head turn it into a strength he gave me
a place in his crappy world until I
screwed up
[Music]
does anybody know what Frank was into on
this there's something going down and
it's big and they were not happy about
what he found we find who did this we
square it counts
if I figure it out I'm gonna make him
regret it I promise you that that's her
that's the girl that Frank was following
I think she found something what happens
to poor people in this city wasn't news
yesterday and it won't be tomorrow
where's everybody go mostly just
disappear this town is run by Moses
Randolph when someone isn't seen for
what they truly are that's a very
dangerous thing if the first inkling of
power works power is knowing that you
can do whatever you want or not one
person can stop you those people are
invisible they don't exist if you
threaten his work he will destroy you
you're all alone you got no idea
[Music]
the webbed up in this somehow in these
people aren't gonna stop it if you got
ahead just like my always turning things
around some people call it a gift but
it'll bring the flesh and just to say
you remember what I said she doesn't
know she doesn't know what don't I know
[Music]
hello hey my friend I got that kid I was
talking to you about him I'm gonna put
him on the phone let you talk them okay
oh yes are you Frank this is Jimmy Hoffa
let's meet you glad to meet you too even
if it's over the phone our friends speak
true I hear you thank you only three
people in the world and one of these not
only one of them is Irish I heard you
paint houses yes I do so where are you
going go to work well you know what it
is a situation going on now Frank
big business and the government they're
trying to pull us down you might be
demonstrating a failure to show
appreciation I know things they don't
know why
you can't miss the big picture sooner or
later
everybody put here as a date and he's
gonna go
you want to be a part of this fight
would you like to be a part of this
history yes I would
whatever you need me to do I'm available
he likes a tough time look out there out
there is the perfect lab you see it I
think so most people can't tell Shelby
maybe Lee Iacocca Ford Motor suppose
henry ford ii wanted to build the
greatest race car the world's ever seen
to win the 24 Hours of LeMans what's it
take I'll take something money came by
when he came by speed wasn't about speed
you need a pure racer behind a wheel
your car ask in miles I don't trust him
an inch we heard he's difficult
no no Ken's a puppy dog
now whatever it is she'll know trust me
you're gonna build a car to beat Ferrari
with a correct and how long did you tell
us that you needed to three hundred
years it's 90 days
[Applause]
this isn't the first time Ford Motors
gone to war we know how to do more than
push paper go ahead girl go to war thank
you sir
do you think you can beat Ferrari
lighter faster
that don't work for nastier
we're gonna make history
you ready I was born ready and mr.
Shelby hit
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey I'm Fred Rogers in here
it's a beautiful day in this
neighborhood a beautiful day for a favor
would you be mine could you be mine
please forgive me my neighbor
hello neighbor mr. Rogers I'm here to
interview you it is so nice to meet you
okay full filing mr. Rogers would please
don't my my childhood this piece will be
for an issue about heroes do you
consider yourself a hero we are trying
to get the world positive ways of
dealing with feelings now like what
there are many things you can do
you could play all the lowest keys on a
pan at the same time
[Music]
we love broken people
[Music]
sometimes we have to ask for that
and that's okay
I think the best thing we can do is to
let people know
that each one of them is preface
[Music]
[Music]
we're just trying to build little bits
of the puzzle what do you remember about
the incident I like this one look at the
map what were you when it happened I
don't remember when you came around
did you see people yes
what were they doing
they were dead we are an awful I like
the oh I'll be both went through the
sooner we get back to a normal routine
the better
Oh Burt that Blackwell said he sent me
exactly where I needed to be into who I
needed to be with is your mother dead
too
yes
I know you were there and I know what
else was in that room
the goldfish before and after everything
is before and after in the middle is the
painting
at glow
master-wife Beefalo in the Oracle after
miracle it survived
there's something important I have to
tell you
until you is it lost
[Music]
even the tiniest things mean something
[Applause]
who took the pain
[Music]
maybe some pro scooter can conquer a bit
[Music]
he's my thoughts she died
I would have given it back I swear
[Music]
after 9/11 everyone was scared scared it
might happen again it was my second day
of grad school next day I changed all my
classes to national security morning Dan
morning center have you seen the story
today in the New York Times evidently
the CIA destroyed tapes of
interrogations of al-qaeda detainees I
want to find out what was on the tapes
why they were destroyed no paper papers
with getting people in trouble met our
place at our place papers how we keep
track of laws last night I found this
he's detaining number 24 you guys see
this no no I should video they
waterboarded him 183 times everything
they got from him was either a lie or
something they already had if it works
why do you need to do it 183 times maybe
one a report comes out people will
finally see that
I've Emily disagree with the narrative
here the United States does not torture
Dan you need to be careful here they
can't destroy the document so I can go
after the next best thing
yeah they claim they save lives but what
they really did was make it impossible
to prosecute a mass murderer because if
what we did to him ever came out in the
court of law the case is over the guy
planned 9/11 we will not allow this to
be covered antennas to gain intel save
American laundries written by the
victors you need to change our house
that even ethic nothing could be further
from the Gemara sea is messy if The
Times had your report we would print it
tomorrow know if it's gonna come out
it's gonna come out the right way
[Music]
so tell me have you done this a lot met
people on the computer surface
don't you find it's always the same you
mean them special followed by them that
but I'll tell my cell press up this time
it'll be different which is why I'm a
star professor
interception my daughter by name is in
fact not Brian it's Roy to the future
how much revenge is worth nearly 3
million Kearney a lot you bloody bet I'm
gonna take it off is that your grandson
it's too soon to be getting so close to
him
I've grown very fond of you do you know
who you are
you're the only person on this planet
who makes me feel that I'm not alone
I know things about you who you really
are you don't want to do this Roy
[Music]
the adrenaline rush
[Music]
what if it is seems like you've had
quite a past enough to last several
lifetimes
I'm just a blink your last rest forever
you know it's very peculiar doing things
you'd never imagine secrets between you
God devil
and the dead know
[Music]
what we know is that Saddam has this
material you don't know that I mean he
just keeps repeating a lie just because
you're the Prime Minister it doesn't
mean you get to make up your own facts
someone in this building has betrayed
their country if you are found to have
withheld information you will be charged
with a breach of the Official Secrets
cousin go don't you think like this
because we know I brought you this
friend be careful this is real jokes for
having in your possession you're a spy
you work for the British government no I
work for British people
I do not collect information so that the
government can lie to the British people
intelligence maybe being manipulated to
take this country to all this stopped
taking Tony plana face value
you had nothing to gain and everything
to lose this could result in a Christmas
do you want to risk it all everywhere
every country biggest demonstration in
human history if we do not go published
we would be conceded that no one had
ever told the people when their
government is lying
[Music]
we did
is extraordinary illegal the public is
entitled to know why my motive was
stopping war and save lives I have to
tell the truth Thomas Alva Edison my
boys and I caught in a jar but before
now is only flashed across the night sky
the future is here oh I'm George
Westinghouse Nikola Tesla
I won't leave a great this provider an
electrical power in the world better
than Edison there's a contest between
you this is a battle for the brightest
minds of America today the impossible
becomes possible
and the man that controls that carnie
controls the future I hope you brought
your checkbooks you want to be
remembered it's simple shoot a president
but if you prefer to have what I call a
legacy you leave the world a better
place than you found it you are building
miracles out of thin air I'm working on
something so new that the world would
never be the same if mr. Edison succeeds
he will set us back so far we may never
recover sometimes we have to work
outside of the rules to get was right
that is how you truly win you got
vultures in every venture but did I
mention that his systems lethal his
current kills people
he's playing dirty you can too
you can't see the real force that moves
things and it's fun
ac/dc it's on cards its currency this is
costing us a fortune
Westinghouse stop my motor that is our
future you're fired
we're never gonna be anything named
Tesla ever again our futures not going
to be paid for bricks fully copper I had
the better system Westinghouse Electric
shall endure the City of Light I built
it already in my imagination it is
perfect there is a possibility you'll be
putting in jeopardy the lives of 28
million people
tonight things could change shake up her
right
one man will rise so what's you trade
inventor six problems radiates I wish I
was the little kids on there I wish I
was the ball the rubbish ahead I grew
what am I being arrested for my being
arrested for huh you think you're hot
cuz you don't know how good I am at what
I do I see you come try real hard be a
twelve-year-old pie fight it's not a pie
fight think it through what you love you
got a job for Justine Kate in case
white-eyed in case you failed in case
you don't work out yes man she's filling
your head full of beer I pump me full of
strength drawing team and I know you got
what it takes you're stalling I know
that's why I'm here I'm your cheerleader
honey boy
don't need to talk about my dad good
take good tape you did it good job
everybody my dad's not the reason that
drink he's the reason I work come here
[Music]
you have been eat I have great sex
I got rodeo clowning so I could never
make it in Hollywood if you start one
idea how do you think it feels to have
my son paying me
how do you think that feels you wouldn't
be here if I didn't pave
[Music]
[Music]
once them that counts the bottles our
place I'm going to the boardwalk coming
are you guys just gonna stay down here
all reactor just going exploring
where that peninsula across the bay
sounds like an adventure
[Music]
you're right
I waited but no one's own uncle accusing
me I leave a buried here we don't tell
anyone
and find you decent no place was a bus
it's real we're so lucky
tell me what's buried here or I shall
read sing when you learn mind in that
mess when you're done playing the bad
boys I promise you pal red it'll mean
jail I've been hearing rumors that my
friends have been talking to the police
I think he'll be more interested in it
breath crazy and red the sunlight giving
people lie
you need to stand up
like comics this is your origin story
are you gonna grow up to be the good guy
[Music]
I don't know you should do I'm working
on a novel it is a story of my life and
my sisters
make it short and spicy and if the main
character is a girl
make sure she's married by the end Wow
I want to be an artist in Rome and be
the best painter in the RAAF's what you
want to isn't a Joe to be a famous right
yes well it sounds so crass when she
says my girls have a way of getting into
mischief so do i this is Meg Amy Beth
and Joe I intend to make my own way in
the world no one makes their own way
least of all a woman you'll need to
marry well you are not married not well
that's because I'm rich Joe would you
like to dance with me
I can't because I scorched my dress and
Meg told me to keep still so no one
would see it I'm lady of havoc manic
Joe is a lost cause
you are your family's hope
I believe we'd have some power over who
we love it isn't something that just
happens to a person
I think the poets night to sue me we can
leave right now I'll sell stories
showing you here should be an actress
and you should have a life on the stage
just because my dreams are different
than yours doesn't mean they're
unimportant new play written by Miss Joe
moss
women they have minds and they have
souls as well as just hearts I want to
be great or nothing and they've got
ambition and they've got talent as well
as just beauty I'm so sick of people
saying that love is just all of them in
it for
[Music]
there are some nature's too lofty Tibet
so who does she marry
[Music]
what brings in today uh I have a hard
time focusing get enough sleep every
night drink how much is enough six to
eight hours
Oh way more than that I had a friend she
was prescribed them at her role and now
she's very alert you know some people
abused that or all right let's get you
healthy I want you to try losing 55
pounds that's the weight of a Siberian
Husky you want me to pull a medium-sized
working dog off of my body it's trying
to feel like everyone's lives are going
places and the mind sort of stuck hold
it hold it please try not to leave all
your stuff in the hallway help me the
third time this month change is possible
if I keep interviewing no one thinks I'm
the right fit I would love you to walk
me through CPR or this doll oh I'm sorry
this child is dead I need to get a teeny
bit healthier
we have rates as well as $129 you do
know that people can run outside that is
zero unlock
[Music]
did you do doing it sorry I'm talking
myself my sister she owns a company
house in pet-sitting all right I'll stay
bad taste in music you're the new girl
I'm the nighttime guy Jaron I'm done
with the drinking I'm don't like this
mode 50,000 people from around the world
are racing today I want to run the New
York City Marathon I think that it's
such a good idea I'm really good at
making profiles god it's not that bad
I'm just gonna give you mine okay
do you know how to spell herpes my whole
life the world told me I was lazy
because the way I looked was trying to
turn my life around everything's gonna
be fine people help doors for me
I'll hold doors for you you changed your
life was never about your weight was
about you taking responsibility for
yourself
we're going backwards [ __ ]
[Music]
hey no if I just want to get weird
[Applause]
and do I go back there dick
you know I normally don't call y'all
about - [ __ ] this is a big deal I get it
it's a whole nother ballgame
yeah you hear about the murders huh
someone dropped this guy off
[Music]
murder murder
yes we got a little carried away last
night no dude what they doing Pulp
Fiction Carl Anthony Kiedis everything a
hard - Keitel ain't in cases do former
hospital yeah I mean for like I mean not
really I mean yeah but like just for
like a little while
I left early you can't come home the
esses hit the fan what the um excuse me
please lady dents dead dick is short for
Richard oh he fell on table saw he got
shot by a hunter alcohol port
[Music]
how did he die
Zeke tell me the truth and my secret
love anymore are you
[Music]
so how would you feel about going to the
mountains for Christmas with grace she
really wants to get to know you guys
that's our mom's hat ah okay I don't
want to leave you here with the kids if
you're not feeling I'm tired I'm feeling
fine it was my idea and it's a couple
days I can do a couple days okay guys
I'm off have fun what is that that's
great
everyone committed suicide a sinner
repent and you will find Salvage things
are very uncomfortable opportunist we're
stuck in a house together
[Music]
what is this powers out where are my
things
it makes no sense what I heard something
hello did you do that we didn't do
anything we're leaving what are you
talking about look outside we're stuck
here
[Music]
okay
you have nothing to be scared about
Alfonso karate you girls been very busy
Avenue movie this is Brendan I won't
fight Claire you're the one I have to
watch out for out here my husband 24
more months left out her services you
girls are gonna be just fully we're
gonna take care of you
I can't even make the rip what they gave
me last night whatever you an idea all
these men working these streets and not
a solid set of balls in there bunch of
guys that don't even remember what
family means so we remind them I don't
want you I want you to teach me
step off my business
baby it's my business man and if you
need to talk to [ __ ] through then get
out of our way I know their rights to
wipe you off the face of the earth
we worked hard for this you want to go
back now what I rather die than go back
you go to war there's no coming back
Claire put a bullet in his head you
girls kill me
[Music]
gentlemen there is a war raging right
now with the Magisterium between those
trying to keep us in ignorance and those
willing to fight for truth and freedom
who will stand with me this kind of
heresy is with highest priority to the
Magisterium I need to know where he's
going and what he intends to achieving
john snake loose is no place for a child
the master is asked if i can find a
place for you and i want you as my
assistant
you're an explorer too just like my
uncle I can teach you to wield power you
must let me manage it we believe there
is an organization that a stealing
children and taking north
sometimes
children coaches disappear I promise to
do everything I could to protect you
from harm it's in a lutely orbit it is
illegal unless approved by the
Magisterium tells you the truth
she has to make a journey one which I'm
afraid includes a great betrayal
trying to pull up something
I suspect it's trying to warn you of a
definition he scores the fight
I can fly your question should be asking
you that we are not Magisterium ever
Muslim I would ask where I could obtain
services and armored bear Eric burns
like people need our help Yorick let's
go give
it's time I know your father died
protecting this city he taught you to
follow your conscience in an often cruel
world would happen worst day of 18 years
how many cops Hey
why were they here they responded to a
robbery
automatic weapons to shooters we have
training Oh what were you when your
father's captain came I asked for you
for a reason I will find out we just
keep hops either one you got to move
fast
cosmatos plates are stolen we will catch
these guys in the next three or four
hours they vanish
are you gonna do this close the eye the
21 bridge is in and out of Manhattan
shut them down three rivers close four
tunnels block oh stop every train and
loop the subways then we flood the
island with blow this may sense the bid
was for 30 keys we walked in the 300
they'll have to open Manhattan by
morning eight dead policeman is one
thing but the stock market version
billions of dollars is quite enough this
whole thing is filthy you know me you've
got to be the move to be hundred killers
of cocaine
what's going on here I just need the
truth that's all I told me you were
feeling the guy kills cop killers
sees his dad and every copy dies
the culture is not
[Music]
we know they're not gonna escape two
pilots gonna cop tinnitus peace person
she's second I will find out why tonight
happy
[Music]